alors quelles sont vos qualités
principales je me bonifie avec le temps
vous aimez les climat très tendu je sais
même pas pourquoi j'ai été engagé ni par
qui exactement mais c'est quoi le poste
réactive process alors le titre so dans
la merde ici à ce box ont fait des ronds
dix pages au fil des op alors j'ajoute
souvent au pde mesurable par simple
princesse
bonjour à tous
tu apprends en bas âge reste ici quand
on a des enfants on se sert d'un goy
c'est la philosophie de la maison
alexandre renet une course folle dans
deux unités petit bémol j'ai dû omettre
de dire que j'avais des enfants
la suite reprenne ce qu'actuellement je
ne vois que tomber se fout de ma gueule
alexandre garder les petits et de la
brède sur de petits sage mais c'est un
seul et même du doubs il aurait trouvé
un joli
son bien la voiture autonome ça c'est la
nouvelle tendance 120 nicolas emerica
chez lui et c'est tout puisque a
décroché pour ma maison en bluetooth
avec de la musique que ça nous calme
quand je vous vois on se tutoie n'en
fait pas un imbécile a voulu connais pas
mais vous la caisse que ces jeux
parfaits j'ai cogné au fenouil
un message de ma voiture quoi je suis
parti me brancher à la borne
mais quelle borne et qu'est-ce qu'elle
fait trop comme cette bagnole